well keeping with insecurity you know
back in the 90s we had talk shows it
would stand up in front of Montel
Williams or Jerry Springer and they
would have the moth and the mask heading
down yeah and now we have internet
comedy discuss whatever yahoo you know
right so how do some would not let that
affect let's suppose they reached a
certain level where they're not people
commenting on what they do whether it's
an article whether it's a
and it's negative you can just turn it
off and silly
it did they look at it and say well this
is how I'm perceived so maybe I should
take with a grain of salt I mean look I
come out of theater and you know most
actors I know and where we're working
plays we just sit to the cast don't read
the reviews because you're if you go on
tonight and this is it's actually
different and harder for actors right
because they're there in front of the
live audience stage actors they're there
in there in front of the live audience
every night and this morning the New
York Times came out with review that
said that they were awful and they have
to go on tonight knowing that everybody
in the audience may have read the review
and you just can't read the reviews you
have to believe in your work now I'm not
saying don't listen to the audience the
audience has a lot to tell us the
audience makes us make our work better
the audience refines our audio refines
the work I'm a great believer in
previewing your movies and sitting there
in the audience and watching and seeing
if they get up and go to the bathroom or
if they laugh at the jokes or if they
cry when you want them to cry and if
they don't the audience has told you
something without ever filling out a
card or making a comment because you
didn't deliver what you want it to
convey to them and then you can go back
and you can recut and reshoot and do
whatever you need to do so I'm not
saying don't listen to the audience but
I am saying that you've got to do what
you believe in and as a very famous
director was told that the audience is
always right except when they're wrong
you